Hey it's me Destin welcome back to Smarter Every Day. You remember a few weeks ago I did a bullet time video
in my back yard with a bonfire? Well this week it's a little bit different.
Check it out. This is a 20 camera setup. Got a software package
that syncs it all together. This is how you do it right,
you know, I did OK in my back yard. So this is Henry from MinutePhysics and he's about to do a
bullet time exhibit here at the US Space and Rocket Center.
(Computer voice) 3..2..1.. Like your style!
(Henry) I think I jumped too soon.
(Destin) That's awesome.
(Henry) That's so amazing. It worked!
Cool it can email your videos.
- No way.
- Yes, yes, yes, OK.
You gotta do this, you gotta do it Destin. [laugh]
You gotta do it.
- Why?
-Cause it's amazing.
- Of course I'm gonna do it.
Alright I'm gonna do it.
(Computer voice) 5..4..
- So this is exactly what happens. Check this out.
- 2..1..
[music]
That was bad. I didn't time it right.
The Matrix gun scene where they fight each other,
Neo and Mr Smith, go see what he does.
(Computer voice) 3..2..1..
So what did we learn here.
On the last video we learned three things. First of all the radius from the center
of all the cameras has to be exactly the same. Secondly the angular offset of each
camera needs to be the same so it doesn't look like it's jittery. And third the exposure
and white balance needs to be the same which requires similar devices. This time our setup
was even better, and that means we can learn more. The first thing that we learned is that
inconsistent lighting is a problem. So there's a flash, there's a flash,
there's a flash. So one bad thing about this setup is you get shadows
at different points. So if we had it to do over again we'd probably bounce some light up into those shadows.
Secondly the cameras have to be pointed at the exact same spot. If you'll
notice on the left, the dot on the carpet kinda jumps around and it throws your eye off.
But on the right, Henry went in and corrected this for every single clip in the video,
which made for a nice smoother turn. So a big thank you to the
US Space & Rocket Center for letting us goof off at your Math Alive exhibit. If you want
to subscribe to Henry's MinutePhysics channel check him out right here. If you want to subscribe to my channel
I'll do what Henry's doing.
Get it?
It's like bullet time in my chair. Anyway it's 2am. It's probably
way more funny to me. I have another channel. You may or may not know that.
It's called Funner Every Day. This week I have a question for you on it. I'm making
posters, it involves lasers and cats. But I have a question as to what words need to go on there.
I'll leave a link somewhere. I'm Destin, you're getting Smarter Every Day.
Thanks.
[ Captions by Andrew Jackson ]
captionsbyandrew.wordpress.com